my name's paula gieron i'm a technical
leader at cisco systems
and i'm here to talk to you about a
project that i'm running there
which is the asami graph database
so today i'm going to give you some of
the background of this project
but also give a short introduction to
what graph databases are and how to do
graph modeling in them
i'll get into what's needed in graph
databases for storage and querying
and i'll explain how asami goes about
doing that
and then i'll finish up with a brief
example of how we use it
so who am i to be telling you about
these things
i've been working on and off with graph
databases now for 20 years
i was in a small team who designed and
implemented one of the first commercial
graph databases
it was called the takana knowledge store
or tux
this was an rdf database
which is a graph standard from the w3c
now tucks disappeared into commercial
history but not before some of it was
open source to create the molgaro
project which i maintained for many
years
i contributed to the sparkle standard
which is a standard query language and
api for talking to graph databases
and i served on the committee for the
second version of the standard
i also have a long history of building
rule systems for rdf and owl
now my first rule system was built into
molgara
but then i moved into a commercial
project
and that worked on any rdf database
through the sparkle interface
now that worked so well that it occurred
to me i could apply this to any graph
database if i had an api adapter
and so i started doing that as an open
source hobby
um
but then shortly after i started at
cisco i showed my boss at the time and
he was very enthusiastic about applying
it to our work so he gave me the
go-ahead to continue doing
open source
work on the company time
so for our own use we needed to select a
graph database from the options
available
the main requirements
were that it should be built in closure
because all our systems were being read
in enclosure
and that eliminated a number of the
better known systems
it also had to be open source
and that eliminated datomic
this leaves us here with data script but
at the time we hadn't heard about that
so my manager said to me just build your
own you can do that right
and i was a bit nervous about saying yes
because i knew from experience just how
big a project like that could be
the man who owned the company when we
wrote to kana and molgara admitted that
he would never have sunk so much money
into it if you'd had any idea just how
big
building a graph database would become
but in this case i knew i didn't need
much
i could do all of the storage in memory
which meant that i didn't need a lot of
the complexity for storing on disk
or in the cloud
and
the rule system itself would only need a
handful of features
it needed pattern matching
it needed join and filter operations
and then needed to be able to filter to
project the results out
but then after i got it all out
i was asked to port it to closure script
so that we could run it in the browser
because we started shifting systems
out of the back end and into the front
end so it was running in both ends now
and then i was asked to add aggregates
like counting on max
and then i found that many of my
colleagues weren't using it because they
weren't familiar with the graph api and
this was very unfamiliar for them
so i wrapped it in a more familiar api
the atomic style
api
and that led not only to them using it
more but the open source community
started picking up on it then as well
now this continued until i realized that
i'd actually re-implemented most of what
mulgara had
and that was a bit of a surprise
because i thought a full database would
be too much for a single person
mongara written in java
is about 100 000 lines
but assami
offering most of the same features
written in closure is about seven
thousand lines
so what is a graph database now many
people aren't familiar with them so with
apologies to people who do know what
graph databases are i'm going to give a
short introduction here
now a lot of people hear the word graph
and they think of charts that they can
build in excel
graph databases have nothing to do with
this
instead they're based on graph theory
from math
now this describes a series of points
called nodes which can be represented as
dots in a picture
the location of the dots doesn't matter
at all
and these nodes are then connected by a
series of lines called edges
now in contrast to general graph theory
graph databases will usually provide a
direction for these edges
nodes are then usually labeled
as are the edges
this creates different kinds of edges
which again is not a usual part of graph
theory
now nodes won't share a label but edges
usually will so here we have edges
some of them are called similar so we
have several things that similar to
other things we have things which are
related to other things
so
each individual edge definition is
described with its starting node the
edge label and the terminating node
and
those definitions form statements and
that provides an alternative
representation for a graph
this is the same information that was
being shown
in the image a moment ago
and as i said the layout of the image
doesn't matter to the math
now with a structure like this we can
model entities as the nodes in the graph
so these entities here represent
people and roles in an organization
and we can show relationships here so
this is a simple org chart of reporting
relationships
each node in this sort of system will
usually represent an entity that can
have various attributes and values in
this case first and last names in the
title
now these look like the sorts of objects
that we see in json data
or in eden which is the closure
equivalent to json
databases like neo4j distinguish between
attributes like this
and edges which join the entities
but most graph databases treat those
values as nodes and the attributes just
become more edges
now what's the point in all of this
well it's flexible
unlike relational tables entities can
have any new attributes connected to
them
or new relationships with other entities
it also allows easy traversal from node
to node
now we can represent all of this graph
for the series of equivalent statements
now for a database to be useful
we have to be able to get data back out
of it
so let's look at a couple of queries
for instance i can ask what the roles in
my organization are
here's a query for that
it asks it has a pattern in the where
clause which is looking for something
that has a title and it calls that role
it then projects that role out with the
find clause
it does this by finding all the
statements statements that match that
pattern in the where clause and then
projects it out
the final result is that set of ceo cto
etc
let's try another query
what's the name of the engineers manager
so this query looks for an entity which
attaches
which it attaches to the variable p
with the title engineer
now that entity reports to an another
entity attached to the variable m
and the m entity will have a first name
of name
now that's the value we want
finding the title matches a single
statement with an entity represented by
the keyword here capital e
we can then find all the reports to
relationships
however we've already established that
the p variable at the beginning have
been set to the keyword e
so we can rewrite that pattern
meaning that it now resolves to a single
statement
giving a single value for the m variable
and that's the keyword c
now at each point here we could have an
entire set
being bound to each variable but
that becomes a graph that's too large to
represent on the screen
looking for the first names is similar
to the reporting relationship
but again we've already figured out that
the m variable should be set to c so we
can reduce it down to again a single
statement
and that gives us just one name
which is carly
carly is the engineer's manager
now how do we go about doing this
the database contains all of those
statements on the left there
which you may notice is ordered first by
the first column then by the second
column and then by the third column
now what do we require from a table like
that to answer our queries
well we may be able to find
we need to be able to find all the
statements that match each of those
patterns
that we were looking at a moment ago in
the query
so
here here are those patterns as an
example
if we look at the first one we need to
find all the statements that match the
title of engineer
now we can do that by iterating through
the entire table but that's not going to
scale at all
so instead we can rewrite the statements
in a different order this time
they're ordered by the second column
then the third and finally the first
column
when they're ordered this way the title
statements can all be found quickly and
the engineer value is found
in sub-order as well in the third column
looking for reports to statements is
just as easy
but we'd already found the value for the
p variable which actually meant that we
could find the required data in the
first set of statements after all
the same thing happens with first names
and we can find but because the
m value can be replaced with c again we
can find it
in that first table
by doing these substitutions we're
automatically getting a join between
each of those patterns
another alternative would be
to
retrieve the entire sets and do a merge
join and occasionally that's going to
make sense
generally in asami though we do these
substitutions
where we do pattern rewriting
in each case here the rewrite is for a
single value but you may be rewriting
say a first name
name and b first name name and c first
name name and you iterate through those
rewrites with the lookups the lookups
are very fast
we can find everything we want using
tables ordered those two ways
as well as this third table which is
ordered
by the third column the first and
finally its second column
there are actually three other possible
orderings but they're redundant we don't
need those
now to be consistent in the way we
handle these tables we'll reorder the
columns so that the initial ordering is
always by the first column
and
we'll know which columns which by the
definition of a table
now the first column
is now full of a lot of repetitious data
in all three of those tables
uh we can remove that
and in the first few instances where so
in a few instances where we've got
repetition in the second column we can
go and remove those as well
now for each
single value in the first columns we can
wrap up the remaining data that it is
that it's associated with and
connected on
and we may notice in the far left table
that those wrapped up values look like
the entity value pairs of our original
data
and that provides a hint that these
things are starting to look like maps
we can also wrap the data in the third
column and attach it to the second
column
now this particular data set doesn't
show
the benefit that you typically get from
it
but if you look in the middle table here
reports to see c has a pair of values of
dna
a lot more typical data sets will have
a greater
a greater effect there
now the way we can model this
is with a series of nested maps
we can map an element to a map of an
element to a set of elements
uh representing that final column
now more recent versions of asami we've
changed that final set we've turned that
into a map as well
it maps that element to a set of
attributes which indicates both
when a statement was created and it
provides a unique id for a particular
statement
this is all built using closures
immutable data structures when we're in
memory
and we also take advantage of these
structures not requiring particular data
types for the elements which is how
we're able to
reorder those maps
using algebraic data types doing exactly
this in scala
got very difficult very quickly to
do it all correctly and
i resorted to using any in the past
closure isn't looking for that kind of
data information and so
this was quite trivial
now we used to restrict some of the data
types from being used in some places
generally things like strings and
numbers should only appear as values
however it turned out that by lifting
that restriction
we've got some interesting use cases
we're able to describe how numbers
relate to each other for instance
we can use strings as attributes
which
doesn't make a lot of sense until you
consider that json uses strings as
attributes
but this is all in memory so far how do
we do this durably
in the cloud on disk that sort of thing
so to store them durably we convert
every element into a number
the tables then become rectangular
arrays of numbers and these are very
easy to store
initially three but now four columns
wide
now the arrays are limited to only 512
elements
and
multiple arrays are then ordered by a
tree structure that references them
now if a block is going to be modified
then it gets copied
and the original the node referencing it
is also copied along with every ancestor
node to the root of the tree
and you can see that these nodes still
reference their unchanged children back
in the original tree so we can make
modifications without changing any
existing committed data
subsequent changes also do a copy on
right with new tree nodes only copying
ancestors that aren't already in the
current transaction tree
overflowing a block near the bottom
there
causes it to split and that's how new
nodes get added to the tree
by the end of the transaction all of the
original data is completely untouched
large transactions may have a lot of new
structure but small transactions don't
actually modify very much at all
now the statements that we're storing
those four numbers
are in the same ordering that we used
for the maps
with a statement id
attached at the end
now that id serves as a double duty as
an offset into an array of statements
in the array format that includes a
transaction id
now having these ids isn't necessary for
most graph operations but it does give
us the opportunity to make queries about
statements which appear in a transaction
or to make
statements about
other statements
where we can reference a statement by
its id
now statements made out of numbers like
this are very easy to work with but we
need some way to go back and forth
between
the numbers and the values that they
represent
asami does this in two different ways
for some values like short strings the
entire value can be encoded into a 64
bit long
we indicate this by setting the high
order bit which makes it a negative
number
and then using the remaining three bits
of the high order nibble
as a data type
if the data has a length like string
does then the next nibble is used to
describe that and the remaining seven
bytes contain the serialized data
for instance
this number on the right here represents
the string hello
we support other data types this way as
well including keywords
and a number of data types based on
numerical values that can fit into 60
bits this includes long values dates
instance booleans
it also takes into account the
restricted range when encoding negative
numbers so you can see here how the
negative two sorry how the two's
complement form only extends up to the
60th bit
we do take full
64 bit length numbers but they can't be
encoded this way
of course
a lot of data can't fit into eight bytes
like this
so this data gets serialized
into buffers
the offset of each item is a number that
represents it so these numbers can be
used for an immediate lookup
then if we have data and we want to find
the number that the data is going to get
mapped to
we have a tree index which holds the
first 16 bytes of
of the data in each node
and that allows most searches in the
tree to be done entirely within the tree
without having to look aside into the
array a principle i've tried to stick to
throughout all of this has been to layer
the implementation with each layer being
described by closure protocols which are
similar to java interfaces
the primary protocol is the graph
this is currently implemented three ways
with one being the durable block graph
which i was just describing now and the
other two in memory
one of the memory graphs supports
duplicate edges
the block graph is built on tuple
storage for statements and data storage
for the number to data mapping
and the implementing objects are both
based on the tree protocol and that
provides basic operations that are
common to tree implementations at the
moment i have avl trees but we're
looking into other trees as well and we
can swap between them
simply by sticking to the tree protocol
now both the trees and the higher level
objects are built over blocks
and these are thin wrappers around nio
buffer blocks in
the jvm
but the main work happens in the
management of blocks allocating saving
and retrieving them
at the moment the
one that we use most of the time is
memory mapped
files and the blocks are coming out of
these files
we
use patterns of allocation so that we
can go well beyond the standard two
gigabyte
range of memory mapping
but we're also able to use box like this
for sending to databases to sending up
to the cloud
anyway we want to manage box
now we're still updating this api to
to also support
an async api
[Music]
so we don't have we're not able to do a
lot of this work in
enclosure script at the moment because
we need everything to be async all the
way down
which isn't just yet but most of this
code is still reusable between closure
and closure script and in fact when we
start swapping out one
uh one of these objects for another so
long as we stick to the protocols we've
been able to swap between various
implementations without incident
so
creating one of these graphs in code
can be done with a create object on a
uri
and the uri describes
um
first of all that it's a sami but then
the next part of the scheme describes
what type of
storage you want to have
but we can also simply call connect
directly on the uri and that will do a
creation as well as connecting to it
in a single step
we can then transact data into that
connection
now there are a few different formats we
can put individual triples or
lots of different things but the most
commonly
used way is simply an array of entity
objects
the dvi dent in these two objects here
is useful for referencing those entities
later on for reading or updating them
so in this case there's just two objects
the first one is elizabeth h 20 and the
second is jane age 22.
now we can do an update by transacting
data to that same
ident
however because sami is based on an open
world assumption unlike many other graph
databases
that would create a whole new age liz
would be age 20 and age 21.
if you want to do an update we have to
inform the database that's what we're
doing
and there's a couple of different
approaches for doing that the one that
i've used here
is has a quote at the end of the age
keyword
that's an annotation which says that we
want to do an update instead
and that can be very useful when you're
updating a specific known attribute
but i keep talking about transacting
things
what's going on when i transact
something
why
when i showed the structures earlier
were the old trees being left unmodified
well whether it's in memory or stored in
blocks the database is all stored
with tree indexes and these trees have
roots which provide access to all of the
data
underneath them
now these routes can be saved along with
a timestamp to describe the contents of
the database at the end of their
transaction
a new transaction will update each tree
creating new routes
and those new routes will get stored
along with their timestamp to save the
database at the end of that transaction
and so on
this gives us an array
of database values
which we can search through to find what
the data look like at any point in time
so if we go back to the code to see this
in action
we can capture the database before doing
a transaction
we get the database from the people
connection and that's original
we can then do
an update to liz's age on the people
connection and then we'll get the
database after that transaction
if we ask
the same query from both the original
and the new data
we'll see that each returns its
appropriate value
so we're getting both the current and
the historical data at the same time
they're both available at once
but we don't have to hold on to
snapshots manually like that instead we
can use the timestamps to find the
appropriate data
now if i calculate the time from
yesterday
i can use that time
with current database to ask what what
the database looked like 24 hours ago
querying both of them like last time
gives the same two different answers
now there are other ways that we can go
through the history as well we've got
transaction ids which are stored in
order of one two three four
um
we we can say that we want to see the um
the data since a particular time or as
of the as of a particular time
these some of these are also available
in daytonic and i believe it's
implemented in a similar way
but it's
very fast to find
the transaction that you want and all of
the data at that point is
is easily readily available
now it's technically feasible to allow
transactions on historical data
but if i did that i'd have git style
branches and that would create a
management problem that
i don't want to go near
um i need to figure out how i want to
safely merge data things like this
so at the moment
historical data is left read-only
but if you do want to work on it you can
copy the data from there and import it
into a new graph
you can create a new graph
by connecting to it in this case i'm
going to put it into memory
and then i can export from there and
import it into the new connection
now
this technique does not preserve the
history but you already had that
however
that could be a bonus if you needed to
remove the history for legal reasons
i could
there's various
places where legislation requires the
data being
dropped off so i can pick an appropriate
point of time import it into a new
database
and then delete the the previous
database
now the title for this talk
promised that i'd show how to load data
in two lines
this is it
you create a connection to a graph
and then you transact your data into it
now a small difference here from some of
the earlier examples is that the code
being loaded now
is pure json as it appears in the file
that means that all the attributes are
strings
which is a strange concept for most
graph databases but i explained this
earlier
it allows us to convert our data into a
graph with minimal modification
also note that unlike
many closed world systems
we can just import data that we haven't
seen before we don't need a schema it
just goes straight in
so once data's been loaded like this you
can issue queries against it immediately
now in this case this is a real world
case that someone approached me with
they had a large packet capture file
that was full of deeply nested objects
that had spaces in some of the keys
so this query is asking for all the
statements
where the
so all statements i didn't care about
the entity or value just the attribute
the a in the middle
i'm looking where the attribute is a
string
and it matches a space regular
expression
now the data that came out of the file
looked like this
obviously there are lots of different
ways to find this kind of thing you
don't need to put it all into a graph
database to do it but it turns out that
this sort of thing is easy and flexible
and
simply by having
json
inserted into the graph database this
way it became very easy to navigate
through data that we hadn't seen before
okay
so
while we usually use asami
either in web pages or as a library in a
in a larger project
we've also built it as a command line
tool using grail vm
now this lets us load data quickly and
executes queries from the repel
or directly on the command line
so
let's see if i can navigate this well
let's have a look at the packet capture
file
sorts of things that we were getting
back and what was happening was that uh
the person with this file wanted to find
keys which had spaces in them
and looking at that it was causing him
all sorts of problems
so to run that we have the asami
program
and we're going to load data into i'll
put it in memory
data
and the file to load up
and i'll execute
this query
patterns if i don't care about the third
element i can skip it
i want to find
where a is a string
and i want to find
where my regular expression
and this is a command line syntax for
regular expressions
as
when applied to
a
should be
there close quote
i hope i've typed this correctly
and so that's loaded up the entire json
file
indexed it turned it into triples and
then run the query engine against it to
get this sort of data
this ad hoc approach doesn't really
scale
exceptionally well because you know the
larger the data that you're working with
the the deeper the indexes get the
indexing is a slow operation so this was
a cut down version at 500k
the original file was 7 megabytes
um
[Music]
so the packets here
is it 583k if i the original file was
7mag
i can run this against the original file
now this takes maybe six or seven
seconds on on this notebook to
index all of that and run it but we get
all of the data back out now
now for instance i can
check to see how this was working in the
original
yeah
by using something like jq to just
reformat the file
and i'll grab it
giving it a little bit of context
and
let's look for that particular
key
and it shows up twice
each time it's inside queries as a key
for
dns lookups
so that data's in there
but to
process this sort of thing through jq
looking for keys which have strings in
them
you can do it it gets very
awkward and tricky having everything
thrown into a
into a graph can make this sort of data
very easy to search for
it also gives us the opportunity to
search down
find
anything which contains
keys like this or values like this
what's
what encapsulates that what does it
contain how does it relate to other
things all of this starts falling out
very naturally when you put import it
into a graph and it gives a
really useful way to explore json
okay
if i return to my slides now
other stuff
there are lots of features in asami that
i haven't looked at here today
the query planner does a lot of work to
ensure that joins are ordered to
minimize work
and it keeps getting more complex with
every new feature that gets added
sub graph identification fast transitive
closures go heavily into graph theory
and
they would take a talk all on their own
and
also the transitive relationships
transitive closures and optional
constraints these are things which are
borrowed from sparkle
we also have efficient sub querying and
optimized aggregation operations
a lot of these things distinguish asami
from other graph databases but they all
have their pros and cons as well
the project is under active use at cisco
and it's made its way into the securex
security products
there's still a lot i'd love to do
and i've made some progress on a few of
them already more recently some people
have even started helping
of course i want every part of it to be
faster
and
new features for users are very
important
but the back end storage still has a lot
of scope for expansion
in particular i want to duplicate a lot
of that query engine to have an
asynchronous api so the closed script
version can talk to a graph that's built
with blocks that are stored in local db
or in an external database
i'm also looking at different tree types
for the data pool
the avl trees work really well for the
the block storage the the couple storage
um fortunately that decision to abstract
all of the layers as as i have has made
this really quite feasible without
uh needing to modify anything else
and
that's everything
uh does anybody have any questions
so
if
so you're looking to do lots of steps
when it
if you're looking at something like a
transitive closure
that does a
space versus time operation whereby it
doesn't try to step across that trust to
find all of the grandparent
relationships for instance or the parent
relationships
and it
joins this data against itself
creating a
every step it doubles the distance that
it's found
and so
it it becomes a log so if you've got say
256 steps
it's
it's performed that in eight steps
to find those
so transitive closures are very fast
um there is some memory usage in doing
that
but it
so far we haven't had any issues with
making with scalability problems of
doing anything like that
it can fall back to doing linear work
but then
you know at one point someone was doing
something which was linear and it took
90 seconds in memory
switching over to using the transitive
closures would took
was 80 milliseconds
so xiaomi hasn't gone into heavy
scalability um at this point the
um
if i wanted to really scale i'd probably
move to neptune to do that
um
the main issue with it is not the
querying it's the indexing
it can take a while to index boxes using
the things that we have at the moment
so
like on your local hard drive with
memory mapped files if you want to index
say two to three gigabytes that can take
over a minute
um but that's actually reasonable for a
lot of local databases
however once it's in
we're still getting sub second
query responses so it's really aimed at
at fast
fast queries
and if your updates are small making
them fast as well but when you're trying
to load large amounts of data then it's
that's a bulk operation that takes time
and that's our major concern at the
moment
with scalability
almost all of the operations
with a couple of the graph analytics as
an exception almost all operations are
lazy
and so it's only accessing what you've
um
uh
if you issue a large complex query it
will only have retrieved blocks
which are relevant to the part that
you're looking at at the moment and as
you iterate through then it'll retrieve
more
so we haven't had any issues with the
laziness at all you
can you can work through it just fine
thank you very much everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you